if in a toxic relationship it's better
to leave for body for your children and
for yourself but why are you arguing why
is the other person arguing with you
are always us let's be realistic
you don't have to argue back that's a
choice
Define abuse abuse can be mentally
physically I need you to Define it
because a lot of times women we throw
around these buzzwords that don't mean
anything anymore that guy is physically
assaulting you right it's best to say in
that marriage because it's no it's not
called physical assault is a very
minority of cases it's a minority so
that's the exception it's not the rule
please give me another example outside
of assault
what is emotional abuse what is it
emotional abuses where them
oh God